-You've made some nice friends
over the course of the year.
-I did. I openly say I los
many, many friends
and many Hollywood friends
I don't have an agent.
You know, nobody would buy
this film.
I made it myself. I funded it.
The first third is a documentary
that my boyfriend and I
just took with phones, and the
second 2/3 are a comedy concer
which no one would buy.
And I'm in the
"Guinness Book of World Records"
for more comedy specials tha
I wrote and directed --
I mean, wrote and produced
than any comedian,
male or female, living or dead
Anyway...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Where did you film?
What city did you film in
for the night of the taping?
-Oh, I filmed --
I did a union taping
at the Broad Theater at
Santa Monica College.
-Great.
-And when I was here in
New York --
You New Yorkers are so great
'cause I got to play
Carnegie Hall sold out
on a Monday
and then Radio City on
a Tuesday, which was amazing
-You met some friends.
-While I've been complaining
about losing some friends,
I've gained some
fantastic friends.
Perhaps you've heard of
Stormy Daniels.
-There you go.
-Yeah, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The classic bathtub shot.
-Well, not classic for Stormy,
'cause she's dressed.
But I don't judge,
like you people.
I don't judge.
And I actually had a dinne
party in Stormy's honor
last week, 'cause I feel lik
when Stormy
comes into town,
she deserves a nice meal.
-Absolutely.
-And it was fantastic.
And people wanted to --
I had a great First Amendmen
attorney there.
Not Michael Avenatti.
You know,
he's out of the picture.
And people were singing.
Jennifer Lewis was there
and sang to Stormy.
And she's a fun girl,
so I'm pro-Stormy.
-And one of the things
that's very serious,
as we're laughing about this
you were detained
by federal agents after
the photo was taken.
-Yeah, like, one of the reason
I wanted to make the movie
for real, is like, I want you to
laugh more than anything,
but I really want you guys
to know that
what happened
to me could happen to you.
So, I was the first person
in the history of this country
to be put under a
federal investigation by the
Secret Service and the
U.S. Attorney's office --
not with a phone call.
They just put me
under investigation.
I was on the No Fly List
for two months.
When I was interrogated
under oath,
I didn't just get,
like, a phone call.
Interrogated under oath.
And they were considering
charging me
with the crime of conspiracy
to assassinate
the President of
the United States,
which holds a lifetime sentence.
So, one of the things I want
you guys to know is --
when you go to the airport
I'm sorry to say,
they can take your phone.
They can take your SIM card.
They can take your passport.
I filed two FOIAs.
I still don't know what wa
on my passport.
Then I was put on what's calle
the Interpol List.
Explain that.
You went to school.
-Interpol is like --
It's like the FBI in England
-Did you go to school or not
-I don't know.
-Okay.
The Interpol is a collection
of police agencies
that work together
with our allies.
So, there's also NAFTA,
and there's five I's.
Do you know the --
-Do I know the five I's?
-Yeah. Do you know the five I's?
-Intelligence, inspiration
imagination --
-United Kingdom -- Oh, my God.
Where'd you go?
-What?
-Where'd you go to school?
-Well, now I feel bad.
It will reflect badly
on the school.
-Wait. Are you part of
that college scam,
like Felicity Huffman
and Aunt Becky?
-I did, yeah.
-Oh, my God!
Aunt Becky got him into school
-Yeah. Go, 'Cats.
-So, anyway, I hope you laug
more than anything,
but I also truly want people t
know, be prepared.
This stuff can happen.
Stuff is getting a lot crazier
and maybe I hope people will
look back and go, "You know,
maybe we kind of
overreacted to that photo,
considering what's
happening now."
Although, I'm very proud
of this joke,
which it took me like a year
to be able to say.
So, to this day, people come u
to me on the street and go
"Go back to ISIS.
You're in ISIS."
And I go, "I worked at
the gift shop for a week.
Get over it."
[ Laughter ]
Thank God -- Oh, thank God
You're laughing.
That was -- I was nervous.
-Well, thank you so much
for being back here.
Congratulations on the film.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was nice to have you,
as always.
That's Kathy Griffin, everybody.
-Thank you.